[Applaudissements]
question oui ah oui c'est au nepad allez
on répond c'est valérie bénaïm tiens
valérie bella inc est en vacances valais
ils savent à ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
vous savez si ça n'est pas vallée de la
lys bas souhaitent
les jeunes de participer comment ça vous
fait des jeux sans moi ouais bah oui qui
sait la chouette vous avez une question
donnée mais oui est ce que madame la
chouette alors et pas des cheveux un peu
taillé and dye fout de ma gueule avec la
question elle pense à data alors est-ce
que vous avez les cheveux tie and dye
valable la chouette c'est ce qu'ils ne
savaient pas ce que ça veut dire moyens
donc au cou non non pas vraiment non non
valérie vous êtes tous là chic un déçu
alors bien sûr on vous embrasse à lui
bel élan
[Applaudissements]